nous sommes le 581 12e jour depuis le
début de la fin nous n'avons plus de
gouvernement si ceux qui ont survécu
sont encore parmi nous préparez vos
pires assurez vous que vos armes soient
nettoyés et trouver un moyen de vous
protéger
doit fuir ne t'arrête pas tant que tu
n'es pas chez ben cours
tu ailles chez ben c'était l'un des
meilleurs agents du fbi a et que j'ai
jamais vue est devenue un survivalistes
pourquoi tu venu ici
ils m'ont trouvé
on va prendre la fille
et on va tuer le fermier
vous avez trop de secondes pour quitter
ma propriété tu peux à nous donner la
fille et me laisser réduire au ranch en
cendre ou b on te tuera et on prendra la
fille quand même
qui m
la nuit risque d'être longue
c'est moi qui décide qui a le droit de
vivre ou de mourir moi vous entrez chez
moi vous essayez d'enlever cette fille
et vous essayez de me tuer en naissains
qui lui est tout seul
vous ai jamais demandé venu ici la fille
est à moi
elle est mon destin un destin sera ton
arrêt de mort